this app feels seriously deranged and
i'm embarrassed to say that i love it
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be debunking specific weight
loss tips and tricks that you've sent me
on tick tock but first let me tell you
about my sponsor billbar so it is snack
time o'clock which we love and these
bars are unlike any other protein bar
that i've tried because they actually
taste like a candy bar and not like a
chalky powdery mealy health food and
there are so many fun flavors so today
let's do
matchy machi
salted caramel because i'm just feeling
a little caramely today oh this is one
of my favorites
[Music]
i forgot how good this one is and this
baby's got 17 grams of protein and you
know what i say about the zero guilt
thing unless you stole them from a baby
all foods are zero guilt these are one
of my favorite bedtime snacks with like
little piece of fruit or i use them on
oatmeal or yogurt to turn them into
balanced snacks so if you want to give
these a try yourself check out the link
in my description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating we
will be talking about pretty extreme
weight loss diet suggestions so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button ring that little
bell and follow me over on tick tock and
instagram at abby's kitchen so if you
missed my previous video on problematic
tock weight loss advice you can check
that out right here but we are back with
another round because let's be real this
app just refuses to let your girl rest
let's dive in weight loss hack so you
want to lose belly fat in just 24 hours
no worries i got you i lost 90 pounds in
just six months and you can do it too
okay so i heard about this where you can
lose belly fat in just 24 hours i didn't
believe it but i said i'm gonna try it
out so this is what you're gonna do so
the first thing that you're gonna do at
eight o'clock you're gonna drink lemon
juice with warm water at 10 o'clock
orange juice or apple juice with warm
water at 12 o'clock you can drink you
some green tea and at 1 o'clock you're
going to drink some carrot juice with
cold water at 3 o'clock you're going to
drink your favorite tea at 5 o'clock
you're gonna drink your favorite juice
and at seven o'clock you're gonna drink
that green tea again so at nine o'clock
you're gonna drink grapefruit juice with
water at ten o'clock you're gonna end
your day the same way that you began
your day so you're gonna have lemon
juice and warm water so the very next
morning i measured myself i was down one
inch i stepped on the scale and i was
actually down two pounds so it really
works ah yes of course it wouldn't be a
weight loss video without a dishonorable
mention of a juice cleanse
for starters i want to make it very
clear that this 24-hour method is very
unlikely to help you lose actual belly
fat if anything it'll just give you the
runs and clean out your bowels which
might make your stomach look temporarily
a little flatter but the key word here
folks is temporary and this is because
you're essentially taking a big hit of
sugars from the juice plus some caffeine
from the green tea which can create a
bit of a laxative effect when we consume
a high concentration of sugars
particularly fructose and other fodmaps
it draws water into the bowel resulting
in the runs there's also no protein fat
or fiber in the state to slow those
sugars down so everything that's going
in is gonna be coming out pretty damn
fast so yeah sure you might lose two
pounds in 24 hours but that will simply
be a bit of waste and a lot of water all
of which you're gonna gain right back
when you eat and drink a normal meal so
if weight loss is actually the goal and
not just like a colonoscopy prep like
day on the loo i say we can take a hard
pass on this
that is one big pilot
next if you're trying to lose body fat
then watch this video i'm about to blow
your mind with this simple swap that you
could be making in your diet that can
make the world of a difference so if you
eat salmon first of all are you buying
farm raise can you stop doing that let
me show you the difference between wild
caught salmon and farm-raised salmon so
this is wild caught salmon i bought this
at aldi super affordable and this is
farm raised salmon when i show you the
nutrition facts for both you're
literally gonna lose your mind so for
four ounces of wild caught salmon
it only has five grams of fat
five it says it right here five grams
you want to know how much fat is in
farm-raised salmon
21.
okay well that's new usually salmon is
pegged as like a dieter's weight loss
bestie so i'm definitely surprised to
see it on this list but let's break it
down first things first are the
nutrition profiles between farm-raised
and wild caught salmon significantly
different well yes albeit ever so
slightly and will often differ by brand
or location where they're caught were
farmed but most of the time we're
usually seeing about a 5 to 10 gram
difference in fat per serving and a very
slight difference in calories because
farmed salmon feed is fortified research
suggests that it's generally higher in
omega-3 fats compared to wild caught
salmon which is a good thing because of
the role in omega-3s in heart health
cognitive function mood and fighting
inflammation so the extra calories that
you're getting are largely due to the
added nutrition of some of those
heart-healthy omega-3s however
farm-raised salmon tends to have lower
amounts of trace minerals and higher
amounts of contaminants so there is like
a bit of a nutrition trade-off here and
this isn't even touching on the
environmental considerations so which is
better
likely depends on your goals and your
values having said all of that to make a
big stink about comparing these two
varieties in the context of weight loss
feels a little bit short-sighted both
are nutritious sources of protein and
healthy fats which we know can help to
support weight loss efforts and unless
you're eating salmon like every day
multiple times a day the calorie
differences are negligible at best so i
say choose a fish that's accessible to
you and supports your ethical and
environmental values we have way bigger
fish to fry oh my gosh that came out way
too naturally let's move on if you're
someone that's wanting to lose fat i'm
going to share with you one of the most
important fat loss tips that help me
lose 60 kilos you need to start eating
more food and i know this may sound
weird but let me explain everyone knows
you need to be in a calorie deficit in
order to lose weight but that doesn't
mean that you necessarily have to eat
less food just less calories so let me
introduce you to something called volume
eating which will make your weight loss
journey 10 times easier volume eating is
when you eat large amounts of foods for
less calories if you focus on low
calorie dense high volume foods you can
actually eat more food for less calories
and lose fat without being hungry all
the time here's a few examples of some
low calorie and high volume foods that
you can incorporate in your diet and
make sure to follow for more so volume
eating is a pretty popular weight loss
strategy which promotes eating a large
volume of food that's rich in water and
low in calories when we volume eat we
transiently stretch out the vagus nerve
which tells the brain that the stomach
is getting full so logically the math
here does check out if we were to look
at weight loss from strictly a calorie
perspective and we do have research to
support low calorie density foods as an
effective weight loss strategy at least
in the short term we also know one of
the benefits of volume eating is that it
indirectly encourages a higher
consumption of those lower calorie foods
like fruits and vegetables which means
you're also getting a lot more fiber
antioxidants and micronutrients in your
day not to mention fiber helps to
promote satiety which can also support
weight loss so all things point to the
fact that volume eating may be a really
good strategy for weight loss however
there are some flaws with this approach
too for one the evidence doesn't confirm
if tricking your body into thinking it's
had a lot of calories when it's actually
just had like a lot of water makes a
difference in the course of a day or if
those calories are made up for once your
body kind of figures out that you've
been trying to dupe it into eating less
don't forget that our bodies still want
us to consume enough calories to thrive
so this often does catch up with us over
time either in tiny amounts
unconsciously or in a full out binge we
also have to think about what it
excludes so thinking of food strictly
from a calories perspective can result
in us edging out a lot of foods that
might be more calorically dense but also
nutritionally dense so i'm talking about
foods like nuts seeds oils avocado nut
butters etc foods that we have actual
evidence to suggest may actually support
weight loss likely by promoting a
feeling of fullness so even if you're
keeping your calories low and you're
losing weight as a result of volume
eating you may also be sacrificing your
overall nutrient intake in the process
it's also worth noting that in some
cases volume eating can actually make
you more bloated and distended even if
you are potentially losing fat and this
is especially true if you're eating a
lot of high fiber foods that your body
is either not used to or irritates your
digestion if you're particularly
sensitive so this is why it's really
super important to introduce high fiber
foods gradually rather than just like
jumping into volume eating from the
get-go
wait a minute lastly even though volume
eating may temporarily satisfy the
physical sensation of hunger we also
know that hunger is about emotional
satisfaction as well so if eating a
massive bowl of lettuce sans dressing
doesn't feel satisfying you're very
likely going to want to continue to eat
more despite feeling physically full and
this is what happens during the
satisfaction hunt where we basically eat
around a craving until we eventually
give in and binge on the food that we
actually want so if you're considering
volume eating as a weight loss strategy
it's worth evaluating if it is a
something you can stick to long term b
if it's well tolerated by your body
and c
if it can meet your needs both
nutritionally and emotionally so this
one is a yes but also a no next
[Music]
for starters does apple cider vinegar
remove toxins or boost your immune
system no and no but can it aid in
weight loss well
let's talk about it now the research on
apple cider vinegar and weight loss is
pretty mixed however what we do know is
that the acetic acid in vinegar may help
to increase feelings of fullness which
may promote weight loss over time for
example one small study found that
consuming vinegar with a meal increase
satiety and cause participants to eat
about 250 calories less in the day
similarly other studies have found a
modest increase in weight loss with
higher intakes of apple cider vinegar
whether consumed after or alongside a
meal however it's important to note that
most of these studies are very small
super short term and even so
only suggest very modest results we're
talking like a couple pounds over three
months and we have no idea what happens
to that weight after those three months
not to mention some of these studies
were confounded by the fact that
participants were also on a calorie
restricted diet wow i wonder what's
responsible for the weight loss
it's also worth pointing out that some
of the research in this area suggests
that the actual reason for a reduction
in appetite and a reduced desire to eat
is simply because of vinegar's
nauseating effects especially when
consumed on an empty stomach as for the
active ingredient itself it really
likely comes down to its acetic acid
content and apple cider vinegar is
actually a bit lower on the food chain
when it comes to acidity level compared
to other vinegar varieties in other
words there is nothing particularly
miraculous about apple cider vinegar
compared to other vinegars it just
somehow won the health halo lottery
in wellness culture world so to
summarize the research on apple cider
vinegar and weight loss is mixed at best
but it's very unlikely to lead to any
dramatic long-term weight loss without
additional efforts next all right if you
need to burn those last five to ten
pounds of stubborn fat i got you this
has been working for me i actually
started it last friday is one tablespoon
of extra virgin olive oil and half of a
lemon let me give my bag
and y'all this sounds really gross but
honestly it's not bad at all
it tastes like lemon
so do that mix it up
and then you just chug it like a shot um
you do it every single morning
5 to 10 pounds off in a week girlfriend
let me know if you try it i feel like
this is one of those old wives tales
that your grandmother swears by that has
been passed down by generations and that
you just blindly accept as fact
however there is zero research to
suggest that this specific combination
in these quantities is somehow like the
magical elixir that will help to burn
stubborn fat also this is basically what
i would use as a salad dressing without
the salt and pepper but what makes it
different is that you're supposed to
drink it on an empty stomach first thing
in the morning oh my god please lord no
so according to this creator the
rationale here is that you are replacing
saturated fat with unsaturated fat from
the olive oil which she claims helps to
promote weight loss and we do have
research showing that unsaturated fats
are associated with a healthy body
weight compared to consuming saturated
fats but this is basically suggesting
that everyone is otherwise starting
their day with like a shot of melted
butter folks both oil and butter will
ultimately add calories to your day so
you're much better off adding that oil
to like a saturating salad or enjoying a
handful of nuts avocado or seeds
honestly sometimes i think people choose
these rituals to torture themselves into
thinking that they hate food guys stop
making it so damn complicated
i want you all to remember that if
someone is sharing a weight loss hack
that promises to make you lose like 10
pounds in a week run the away this is
not a healthy rate of weight loss and
can actually have severe implications
for our nutrition status metabolism and
muscle mass so if you take anything away
from my commentary here it's that
theoretically weight loss comes down to
a calorie deficit albeit a disclaimer
that even that isn't as simple as
calories in calories out as so many tick
tock bros will make you believe if you
want to know the truth about calories
please leave me a comment below and i'll
make a whole video on that but any sort
of random punishing elixir or ultra
specific rule is just a distraction for
you to focus on to convince yourself
that
this diet will work that this diet will
be different than all the rest and if
you only follow this rule to a t that
you'll finally lose those 10 pounds
folks the basic formula for weight loss
in a closed system at least
will never change it just comes down to
tweaking it in a way that feels most
sustainable for you and if you're
looking for some sustainable weight loss
tips i have a whole video right here but
on that note that is all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what or who i should
review next subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]